merci Stéphane Raget de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure et
merci
du Rhône membre de reconquête le parti
d'Éric Zemmour on va parler évidemment
de la réforme des retraites nouvelle
journée de mobilisation avant-hier mon
suivi que les précédentes est-ce que
l'exécutif est en train de gagner le
pari de l'essoufflement de la
mobilisation il a considéré que la fer
était pliée on a entendu le ministre là
tout à l'heure et il souhaite discuter
avec des syndicats à condition que les
syndicats soient d'accord ça c'est tout
Emmanuel Macron veut bien discuter mais
conditions d'accord avec lui
je crois que c'est Monsieur Veyron qui a
fait savoir que la réforme des retraites
était derrière nous désormais donc
quelques quelques soit la réaction des
Français leur mobilisation moindre ou
plus importante considère que c'est
terminé c'est votre cas aussi vous dites
il faut continuer à mener la bataille
politique la bataille politique oui la
bataille industrielle la bataille des
naissances parce que la solution elle
est là en réalité
cette cette réforme à mon avis elle est
injuste elle est injustifiée la
précipiter c'est une réforme de facilité
alors si vous considérez qu'elle est
injustement
et qu'on fasse preuve de d'intelligence
et de réflexion quel est le problème
1,4 cotisants pour un retraité c'est
vrai que le chiffre il est très parlant
et que l'on priori on a plus les moyens
il y a quelques années quand il y avait
trois à quatre cotisants pourquoi parce
que la pyramide des âges fait que la
population a vieilli que la natalité
n'est plus là et bien il faut je dirais
relancer une politique nataliste en
France en faveur de la famille française
si vous me permettez c'est quoi la
famille française et ce sont les
Français en France ce sont les familles
françaises c'est en favorise
exclusivement la famille française par
des mesures fiscales par des mesures de
en grille
le président Orban a mis en place une
politique nataliste en faveur de la
famille hongroise
à partir de trois enfants depuis plus
d'impôt sur le revenu on peut avoir la
nationalité française pour vous
absolument je pense que c'est une
solution
des retraites ça passe uniquement par la
natalité
d'abord alors c'est une mesure à moyen
voire à long terme on va pas faire des
enfants et des travailleurs surtout en
quelques mois mais ça passe par là parce
qu'il nous faut une main d'oeuvre
française à condition d'avoir des
emplois au bout à condition d'avoir
avant ses emplois une formation pour les
jeunes qui soient digne de notre pays
donc il faudra un système scolaire un
système de formation qui soit adapté il
faudra une réindustrialisation
évidemment
sur un coup avec Eric Zemmour nous
sommes tout à fait d'accord et là toute
une politique de fonds
à mener et une réflexion évidemment
Emmanuel Macron son gouvernement ne sont
pas prêts à cela comme ce prédécesseur
d'ailleurs
quant à moi et
[Musique]
d'une réforme bâclée d'une réforme
imposée d'une réforme qui encore une
fois ne s'attaque pas au fond parce que
dans 10 ans on le sait en disant il faut
chercher l'argent ailleurs là où vous le
dites est-ce que ça va permettre de
sauvegarder le système par répartition
chercher l'argent où il y en a il existe
l'argent et il peut très bien
l'introduction d'une part de
capitalisation je suis favorable à ce
que ce système soit conservé mais rien
ne nous interdit d'étudier des solutions
alternatives ou complémentaires donc pas
uniquement financé par les activités de
capitalisation on pourrait en discuter
on pourrait en débattre on pourrait
l'étudier il faut pas rester enfermé ce
que je vous dis aujourd'hui c'est que le
système de répartition peut être très
bien conservé à condition non pas de
faire porter aux Français de leur de
leur infliger un sacrifice
supplémentaire mais c'est l'État qui
doit se sacrifier qui doit un petit peu
travailler se remettre en question en
allant chercher l'argent où il y en a
parce qu'il y en a et cessé de le
gaspiller Marine Le Pen dit que si elle
est élu elle reviendra sur cette réforme
est-ce que vous y croyez est-ce qu'elle
aurait raison de le faire
Marine Le Pen a tellement promis de
choses qu'elle n'a pas tenu avant même
d'être élu elle avait même elle avait
fait savoir que lorsqu'elle serait élue
et bien elle reviendrait sur le mariage
homosexuel elle ne démarrez pas mais
elle l'abolirait cette loi sur la
mariage homosexuel elle avait fait
savoir qu'il y aurait un référendum sur
la peine de mort et puis plus de
référendum alors une fois deux fois
plus c'est pour ça aussi que je suis
parti à force d'abandon non non je ne
pense pas qu'elle y revienne on va
parler des dernières mobilisations qui
ont été émaillées de violences dans
plusieurs villes ça a été le cas à Rouen
on retrouve pierre durant Gratien
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
chef d'édition à la rédaction de
Tendance Ouest du côté droit revient
avec vous sur la manifestation mardi
pierre qui a été générée en dégradation
et en affrontement avec la police et
l'heure est aujourd'hui au compte
bonjour oui effectivement à Rouen comme
ailleurs on commence à compter après les
deux dernières manifestations du 23 et
du 28 mars les deux manifestations
post-49-3 finalement qui ont donné lieu
à des débardements des débordements en
marge des cortèges alors il y a bien sûr
les abribus il y a le mobilier urbain
qui est brisé ce qui coûte très cher
aussi c'est le bitume qui est dégradé
par les nombreux feux de poubelles les
feux de palettes de pneus et qui va
falloir refaire à cela on peut ajouter
la mobilisation des agents pour nettoyer
réparer et qui ne font pas autre chose
pendant ce temps et puis le préjudice
aussi d'être activité pour les
commerçants du centre-ville notamment
bref à Rouen pour la municipalité
estimation au doigt mouillé pour
l'instant cela fait au moins un million
d'euros de dégâts après les deux
dernières manifestations la ville d'Oran
qui a porté plainte contre X alors qui
doit payer la facture
très clairement pour le maire de Rouen
le socialiste Nicolas Mayer Rossignol
vous le connaissez désormais pour avoir
été candidat au poste de premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste
dernièrement évidemment toujours dans
cet élan son discours est très politique
c'est pas forcément d'ailleurs tout à
fait facile à tenir pour sa famille
plutôt modérée d'un côté il doit
déplorer et condamner fermement les
violences les dégradations ce qu'il fait
sans ambiguïté mais de l'autre en faire
vente opposant à la réforme des
retraites il saisit aussi avec une
conférence de presse d'ailleurs hier
l'opportunité d'épingler l'État et même
directement Emmanuel Macron responsable
du pourrissement de la situation selon
lui et aussi d'ailleurs le seul capable
de l'apaiser et pour l'apaiser je vous
le donne en mille la solution de Nicolas
mairossignol c'est le retrait de la
réforme ravier
bonjour Stéphane Ravier question qui
découle directement de ce que l'on vient
de dire quand on sait que le président
est responsable de la cohésion dans le
pays que l'État est responsable du
maintien de l'ordre est-ce qu'il doit
payer finalement pour les dégradations
en marge des manifestations en somme ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec le
socialiste Nicolas Mayer Rossignol c'est
un comble ça vous vous évoquiez ce
mobilier urbain ce bitume tous ces
équipements publics c'est déjà l'État
qui a payé c'est-à-dire vous c'est à
dire moi c'est-à-dire vous cher Monsieur
seul contribuable qui a déjà payé tout
ça et ça serait au contribuable à payer
à nouveau la casse où les conséquences
de la casse on a inventé le concept de
pollueur-payeur bon ben on peut
l'étendre à casseurs payeur c'est au
casseur à payer ce qui a été cassé pour
que ça soit réparé ou remplacer non mais
c'est on va pas payer comme ça deux fois
en plus des violences physiques sauf
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les collectivités
qui payent
et les collectivités
l'État c'est toujours le même au final
l'argent il n'y a pas l'argent public il
n'y a que l'argent des contribuables et
le contribuable qui voit donc son
environnement dégradé saccagé quand il
n'est pas lui-même physiquement agressé
les commerçants les policiers et en plus
derrière il faut payer il y a une triple
injustice il y a une triple
agressions payeur
une autre question vous avez votre
réponse j'ai eu ma réponse ça veut dire
que vous considérez qu'il y a pas eu de
faille dans le maintien de l'ordre du
coup le maintien de l'ordre lui il peut
pas tout faire le maintien de l'ordre
les policiers sont on le sait sur sur la
brèche depuis plusieurs jours plusieurs
semaines ils sont harcelés eux-mêmes
physiquement agressés ils ne peuvent pas
tout empêcher ils diraient qu'ils
arrivent à préserver l'essentiel ensuite
comment peuvent-ils empêcher des
vitrines d'être brisées d'habitude
d'être démonté des abribus saccagées
pour vous il n'y a pas eu de failles
dans la stratégie
de la chaîne ceux qui sont sur le
terrain ceux qui emprunt par le moi
l'expression plein la poisse
c'est-à-dire les policiers à qui
j'apporte un soutien total
en amont il est certain que le ministre
de l'Intérieur n'a pas pris les
décisions qui s'imposaient et depuis
longtemps ces groupes de casseurs
ultra-violents de l'ultra gauche et
antifa Black Bloc etc ils sont connus
tous connus reconnus ils ont tous été
plus ou moins arrêté une à plusieurs
fois c'est en amont qui devrait être
arrêté c'était en amont qui devrait être
bloqué j'ai entendu récemment sur un
média une syndicaliste policier faire
savoir que ils savent les renseignements
généraux savent
ça s'appelait comme ça mais donc les
services de police savent quand ces
Black Blocs vont intervenir par où ils
vont arriver dans les manifestations à
quelle heure
qu'il y a pas de fait pour les arrêter
j'en sais déjà vu des arrestations
préventives pendant la coupe du monde de
football on avait
imaginer que des groupes d'ultra-droites
aller saccager aller déferler sur Paris
et ils ont été certains membres ont été
jugés comme tels ont été arrêtées tous
relâchés sans aucune condamnation mais
ils ont subi des arrestations
préventives pourquoi aux uns et pas aux
autres surtout que quand les autres
l'ultra gauche les Black Blocs et autres
et autres antifa militant d'extrême
gauche alors que cela on sait très bien
qu'ils vont passer l'action ils sont
déjà passés à l'action surtout quand ils
sont soutenus peu ouprou par des députés
de la nation on a entendu ce député
écologiste faire partie des
manifestations dans le cadre justement
d'une rassemblement important interdit
bon alors je crois que le ministre de
l'Intérieur pourrait en réalité agir en
amont mais il ne le fait pas les
policiers le regrettent parce que on
pourrait donc empêcher c'est c'est
saccage mais Gérald Darmanin a décidé de
ne rien faire il faudrait peut-être lui
poser la question de savoir pour quelle
raison
il a mis un dispositif de sécurité
inéditation d'avant-hier 13000 policiers
sur tout le territoire justement pour
sécuriser les manifestations et empêcher
ces Black Blocs de comète des violences
une fois une fois que c'est quasiment
trop tard une fois qu'ils sont gérés sur
le terrain d'opération de leurs
opérations c'est quasiment trop tard moi
je pense qu'on pourrait agir en amont
pour empêcher la casse alors là on va
pas demander à Monsieur Darmanin de pays
lui tout seul la casse mais on peut
exiger de lui qu'il prenne des décisions
qui s'imposent désormais pour éviter que
ces Black Blocs se réunissent et et et
commettent leur saccage
je l'avais presque désormais dans tout
le pays on va remercier pierre depuis
Rouen merci
rédaction de tendances ouest merci
beaucoup pierre on va passer à
l'actualité du Sénat ou est-ce que
aurait dû être l'actualité du Sénat
cette semaine le projet de loi
immigration qui a finalement été reporté
alors verra-t-il le jour et sous quelle
forme on va ça avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Mathias ça reste
[Musique]
bonjour Oriane et Mathias immigration
devait donc commencer son chemin
démocratique au Sénat cette semaine
finalement c'est pas le cas est-ce qu'on
peut parler de parcours chaotique
remontons le fil ensemble Oriane depuis
des mois on évoquait un projet de loi
pour contrôler l'immigration et
améliorer l'intégration portée à la fois
par le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
Darmanin et le ministre du Travail
Olivier du soft premier février le
projet de loi est présenté en Conseil
des ministres mi-mars en pleine
discussion sur les retraites au Palais
du Luxembourg la commission des Lois du
Sénat examine le texte et là il y a des
premiers remous la majorité sanatoriale
de la droite et du centre qui n'est pas
d'accord en son sein durcil texte la
suite on la connaît le texte est l'une
des premières victimes collatérales de
la crise politique soulevée par la
réforme des retraites le président de la
République en concertation avec le
président du Sénat Gérard Larcher décide
finalement la journée son examen dans un
contexte jugé trop abrasif la journée ça
le texte n'est pas abandonné pour autant
Mathias non le texte est bien reporté
Oriane car comme l'a rappelé Olivier du
soft il y a quelques jours le
gouvernement reste très attaché à
l'intégralité des dispositions tant
celles qui permettent de mieux réguler
l'immigration que celle qui permettent
de mieux intégrer par le travail c'est
bien la méthode qui devrait changer
Emmanuel Macron voudrait découper le
texte les sénateurs préfèrent eux parler
de saucissonnage mais selon le ministre
chargé des Relations avec le Parlement
Franck ryther il était hier sur ce
plateau rien n'est encore décidé et on
peut pas nous dire d'un côté il faut
faire des textes plus courts c'est trop
compliqué on y arrive pas et en même
temps éventuellement reprocher de faire
des textes plus courts tout en gardant
évidemment une cohérence d'ensemble moi
j'entends le message du Sénat qui est
dit attention on peut pas sur des sujets
aussi importants perdre une cohérence
d'ensemble pour une compréhension de
globale de sujets mais ça je le
comprends très très bien après comment
ça se traduit en termes de textes de loi
de contribution des parlementaires des
propositions tout ça n'est pas encore
définitif qu'est-ce qui devrait se
passer dans les faits Mathias et bien
tout porte à croire qu'on devrait bien
aller vers un saucissonnage dans des
plaises à franquiester plus un mais bien
trois textes un premier projet de loi
issu du gouvernement inspiré du rapport
du sénateur LR François de Noël buffet
contenant les mesures les plus
techniques les plus consensuelles aussi
sur la simplification des procédures de
demande d'asile et le contentieux des
étrangers un deuxième texte plus dur
issus des républicains sur l'éloignement
des étrangers délinquants et
l'application des auqtf enfin un dernier
texte qui émanerait de la majorité
présidentielle qui sur le papier
pourrait séduire la gauche sur
l'intégration des étrangers par la
langue et le travail en reprenant
pourquoi pas le titre de séjour métier
en tension mais seul sénateur
saucissonner un texte qui ne traite au
final qu'une thématique répond selon
vous une stratégie d'apaisement ou une
stratégie politique cela répond à pour
le gouvernement à essayer de sauver ce
qui pas encore l'être je crois que on
n'a pas voulu remettre de l'huile sur le
feu des manifestations de l'agitation et
on a voulu éviter pour un temps que les
milices d'extrême gauche ne se
déchaînent à nouveau considérant que
l'immigration est un bienfait sinon pour
l'humanité en tout cas pour la France
que c'est une chance pour la France il
faut absolument pas restreindre
ce torrent se déferlement ce grand
remplacement des milices d'extrême
gauche qui sont
de plus en plus violente et attaque tout
ce qui n'est plus à gauche on en parlait
il y a quelques minutes mais donc non
mais ce report est une autre chose ou
vous regrettez que ce texte ne soit pas
examiné je voudrais quand même rappeler
que ces ministres d'extrême gauche
attaquent les militants qui s'opposent à
l'immigration des militants de droite en
général et pas seulement de reconquête
il n'y a pas longtemps à Nice il y a
quelque chose à Nice ils se sont livrés
à des actions sur sur des militants qui
voulaient simplement débloquer une fac à
Marseille ce sont des militants de l'uni
qui ont été agressés sauvagement par des
par ces milices d'extrême gauche et je
pense que si ce projet de loi n'est été
venu sur la table ces milices ce serait
déchaînés
il ne faut pas céder face à ces milices
d'extrême gauche il faut il faut les
combattre
il faut le retard dans le bras il faut
que force doit rester à la loi et que la
loi non pas sur l'immigration parce que
c'est la 28e loi je crois on est à peu
près 30 la 30e loi sur l'immigration
depuis le début des années 80 il faut
une loi une loi
entre l'immigration or cette loi n'est
pas une loi contre l'immigration mais
une loi de régularisation de
l'immigration massive en réalité voilà
c'est tout vous regrettez son report
bien sûr mais vous ne regrettez pas son
saucissonnage vous le regrettez
peu importe peu importe la façon dont
sera présenté le tout c'est que l'on
puisse finalement aborder le fond alors
que ça soit en trois en trois parties ou
en un seul bloc moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que le débat ait lieu que l'on
puisse discuter débattre et voter sur le
fond le fond que moi
j'estime être l'urgence c'est non pas de
de régulariser les clandestins comme
cette loi nous le propose et nous
l'impose mais de combattre l'immigration
clandestine et donc on va régularise
en quoi est régularise les clandestins
de séjour provisoirs a bien dit le
ministre pour des personnes qui sont
déjà là et qui devront faire un certain
nombre de mois sur le territoire et
travailler un certain nombre de mois
avant d'obtenir ces titres de séjour on
sait bien que ce provisoire va durer ça
c'est évidemment il se fout de nous
géraldavie se moque de nous c'est
improvisoire qui va durer et ces métiers
en tension c'est encore une fois
solution de facilité de de couardise de
je sais pas de fainéantise plutôt que de
réformer l'État c'est si ces métiers si
ces employeurs notamment dans la
restauration ou dans le bâtiment ont du
mal à trouver alors qu'il propose des
emplois à trouver preneur chez nos
compatriotes c'est parce que ces métiers
sont mal payés c'est parce que les
métiers sont difficiles parce que les
horaires sont compliqués notamment dans
la restauration et que nos compatriotes
ne veulent pas travailler pour les
salaires de misère ce qu'elle va
peut-être le plus accepté un travailleur
un travailleur clandestin et bien il
faut que l'État se réforme et si ces
employeurs c'est ce que je voulais dire
pardonnez-moi si ces employeurs ne
peuvent pas proposer des salles des
salaires dignes c'est parce qu'ils sont
écrasés par des charges patronales c'est
parce que l'État ne veut toujours pas se
réformer nous avons des prélèvements
obligatoires qui sont les plus élevés
quasiment de l'OCDE donc c'est à l'État
à faire l'effort de se réformer sur le
plan fiscal pour alléger cette pression
ce qui permettra au patron de proposer
des salaires plus élevés et nos
compatriotes y répondront
provisoires est-ce que finalement le
saucissonnage de steak va vous permettre
d'en voter certains notamment celui par
exemple sur l'application des occultés F
nous verrons nous verrons le texte nous
verrons le texte mais bon
il a déjà été examiné en commission des
lois parce que là vous retenez la partie
titre de séjour c'est un texte qui vise
aussi à faciliter les obligations qui
étaient le territoire français à durcir
la politique d'intégration le Sénat a
durci encore plus ce texte en regroupant
en red durcissant pardon les critères du
regroupement familial en réformant
l'aide médicale d'État pour la
restreindre qu'est-ce qui ne vous va pas
ça vous ne voterait pas c'est parce que
c'est une amélioration tout ce qui va
dans le sens de l'amélioration du combat
contre la lutte contre l'immigration
dans son ensemble et pas seulement
l'immigration légale dans son ensemble
puisqu'il y a 300 000 étrangers qui
rentrent dans notre pays chaque année
qui sont démunis de tout qu'il faut
assister en tout pendant qu'on dit à nos
compatriotes qu'il faut qu'il fasse de
sacrifices sans sacrifice je ne
l'accepte pas et depuis le texte de la
droite sanitaire le texte du Sénat qui a
été qui a été durci il va dans le bon
sens mais moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est
l'application parce que le code pénal il
est il est déjà
c'est les moyens ensuite qui ne viennent
pas c'est la volonté du gouvernement qui
ne vient pas les occultés et on sait
très bien que ce n'est pas appliqué
alors moi c'est
il n'y a pas d'amour il n'y a que
l'épreuve d'amour il est alors moi moi
c'est une intention c'est une intention
qui ne répondez pas vous le vôtre
je verrai je l'étudierai dans sa
dernière mouture lorsqu'il viendra
lorsqu'il viendra sur la table mais tout
ce qui va dans le sens évidemment de la
lutte contre l'immigration et donc de la
protection de nos compatriotes dans tous
les domaines économique social
identitaire sécurité parce que
l'immigration évidemment ces
conséquences ruisselles sur dans tous
ces domaines Marseille 54% de la
délinquance et du aux étrangers donc
évidemment que si ça va dans ce sens je
le soutiendrai mais je souhaite que nous
allions en réalité beaucoup plus loin
parce que c'est urgent et depuis
longtemps merci Mathias à tout à l'heure
on va parler d'un tout autre sujet dans
le club avec un reportage et on verra la
question des homicides routier avec vous
un mot de peut sur votre partie sur
reconquête pour terminer il y a des
sénatoriales au mois de septembre est-ce
qu'il y aura des candidats de reconquête
au sénatorielle nous sommes en pleine
réflexion
nous sommes en pleine réflexion sur
sur la pertinence d'en avoir ou sur le
fait que c'est difficile pour vous d'en
trouver non d'en trouver non c'est pas
difficile on réfléchissons à la
l'opportunité
dans présenter pourquoi c'est pas
forcément important c'est important
d'avoir des candidats et aussi des élus
mais les candidats à la candidature ce
monsieur manifeste ça c'est pas un souci
vous pensez que vous pourrez en avoir
vous avez très peu d'élus
écoutez ça le terrain le terrain nous y
sommes sur le terrain nous n'avons pas
abandonné le terrain à chaque fois que
nous pouvons défendre j'allais dire la
cause nationale nous sommes là pour
défendre notre identité c'est
reconquêtes qui est sur le terrain
lorsque les nos statues veulent sont en
voie d'être des boulonnés lorsque nos
enfants sont victimes du walkisme et de
l'islamisme à l'école c'est reconquête
qui est sur le terrain alors mais où
vous pourriez avoir des sénateurs
pourquoi dans les départements sur le
terrain aussi au sénatorial nous sommes
au mois de mars c'est pas encore tout à
fait
urgentissime nous y réfléchissons avec
les membres du mur exécutif autour de
notre président Eric Zemmour après il y
aura les européennes en 2024 qui pour
conduire votre liste aux Européennes et
bien le Bureau Exécutif il réfléchit je
n'ai pas encore la décision
celui ou celle qui sera
investi désigné sera celui ou celle que
je suis tombé
Eric Zemmour lui-même Marion maréchal
que je crois que le bureau en discutera
le moment venu c'est ce qui vous le
disiez il y a les sénatoriales d'abord
il y a tant de choses on n'est pas non
plus dans une démarche électoraliste
l'intérêt du pays
les l'actualité nous pousse quand même à
répondre aux questions des Français qui
s'imposent aujourd'hui
pour survivre il a pas besoin bien sûr
que bien sûr que nous serons présents à
l'occasion de ces élections européennes
et elles sont importantes
Eric évidemment on est convaincu comme
les autres membres du bureau comme
l'ensemble des cadres de reconquête
est-ce ce qui Eric souhaite être
candidat s'il le souhaite il l'a ou pas
dans les deux cas et en discutera
pas encore il a pas fait connaître sa
décision
un dernier mot vous êtes encore en
contact avec Jordan Bardella le
président du Rassemblement national plus
les dix sont coupées
[Musique]
il y a pas la possibilité d'un
rapprochement avec le rassemblement
national
nous sommes dans une démarche de
rassemblement des droites bon il
faudrait que le rassemblement national
soit à droite
c'est-à-dire que nous avons une
direction en réalité parce que Jordan il
préside mais ne décide pas
qui qui décide et l'on entend et
l'envoie Marine Le Pen à adopté une
ligne de plus en plus à gauche et
Jordan est là pour essayer de d'empêcher
les lectorats droitiers du rassemblement
national de rejoindre reconquête
mais ce que je vois ce qui est clair
avec Marine Le Pen qui décide c'est
qu'elle est tout à fait hostile à se
rassemblement des droites ce qu'il a
cornérise et ce qu'il a condamnera à
perdre une fois de plus si
d'aventure elle était candidate une fois
encore pour la quatrième fois aux
élections présidentielles à l'élection
présidentielle mais nous continuons à
attendre la main bien sûr et en
particulier au peuple du rassemblement
national il y a ces cadres locaux qui
eux sont d'accord avec nous avec ce
rassemblement merci Stéphane Ravier
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
dans 20 minutes dans le club on le
disait débat sur la question des
homicides routiers faut-il créer le
délit domicile routier et il faut t-il
durcir les peines ce sera le débat du